[Music]
recently this week we've had loads of
dms talking about the ultimatum um we
even started we started watching it
before well you start you watch it
before you started watching before i
think i watched it i think i was one i
watched one episode before you started
watching it yeah um i was gonna watch it
anyway but then we had
tons and tons and tons of dms about it
and yeah we hopped on we did a quick
binge sesh and we did
um yeah man we're about to review the
thing the show is juicy
the show's juicy it's dude the show is
due
juicy this the show is so juicy that we
had to flip up switch up our drinking
habit just for today we're gonna get
[ __ ] with it
sipping through straws i want to hold my
cup the whole time we go for it [ __ ]
with it
we're going to get chatty cat oh it's um
so for those that don't know i haven't
seen the trailer i don't know anything
about the show ultimatum the premise is
there are
five or six couples in each couple
one person um gave the ultimatum i.e
they want to get married or by the end
of this experience
they're going to either leave
with someone else or leave quite quite
empty-handed single yeah yeah um
that's basically long story short but
that ultimatum
first three weeks
um they're with a completely different
person
the next three weeks they're with their
original partner
so you can imagine how yep and then they
have the and they have the optimization
at the end yeah
who do you choose right so there's gonna
be bear spoilers going on we're gonna do
a full breakdown of the season it's
going to get juicy best parts worst
parts favorite characters least favorite
characters uh different traits it's
going to yeah we're going to try and get
it done as quickly as possible but it's
probably going to be a lengthy one yeah
so buckle up here's a huge spoiler yeah
and this is the the sng breakdown of uh
the ultimatum okay cool so but let's
just go through couples but let's go
through a couple of original couples um
yeah all original couples okay okay
first one hunter and alexis yeah
alexis
alexis doesn't know what she wants
she is one of the most materialistic
people i've ever met she's a joke
material and all she knows is finance
all she wants
that's all she cared about she's like 25
in it i thought she was looking for she
was 47 yeah she looks old
she looks old she looks old fast she's
had work done she has and it's done it's
the opposite effect it's it's weird she
sat down with colby and said my man
needs to be making x y and zed i want to
do this i want to use that certain
lifestyle i'm not looking to drop i'm
going to be i want to exceed that
lifestyle yeah yeah yeah colby sat back
he said raw this is not the app for me
this is i can't see a future with you
babe sam he literally she sat down in
the restaurant in it and was like
obviously i'm feeling you we had a great
conversation
what are you saying i said i'll be
honest
i don't see a future with you
she said rash she said what how can you
say that so early on i'm obviously
giving myself to you you're my favorite
et cetera how can you say that so early
on she said babes
i'm just not attracted to you like
that's literally all there is to
panicked i'm just not attracted to you
she thought she was the bee's knees when
she walked in she thought she was the
buffett thing in there she thought she
would clean
up she literally thought i'm the buffest
thing in here i'll get whoever i want
the one person she wanted said big man
you're not attractive
she ran up to madeleine and said kobe is
a piece of [ __ ] and you could do better
so embrace this experience
fam she's a hater she's a hater she
embraced this experience while she was
talking to hunter yeah
while she's on a date with your man she
said enjoy this whole thing
nah i know he bought you here but he's a
piece of [ __ ] you can do better
he's scumbag yeah [ __ ] it out she's
nasty you know she is nice alexis is
nasty when she doesn't get her way true
colors bro true colors and then she
tried to send for him again in the on
the decision day
at the table yes yes yes she did she
tried to send for him again i want to
interject sorry i don't think he's a
nice guy because lauren was saying all
these nice things or whatever or april
might have been saying something nice
she was like i'm sorry to interrupt but
nah he's just not a nice guy he's a fake
he's this and that all because and then
she tried some
she tried to spin a lie she tried to
spin a line and said basically said he
out of the blue you just called her ugly
or something like that the first she
said the first thing he called me was
ugly or something like that literally
the f i tried to have a nice
conversation the first thing out of his
mouth is that you're like
you're unattractive or something like
that definitely didn't say that's a lie
definitely didn't say that sometimes i
don't know how these cameramen keep
their mouths shut
you'll hear me like if i'm the guy with
the mic these boom mic guys yeah i'm
like that's a [ __ ] lie and look you
can see when the camera fans to me and i
got my my headset and i'm like that
i'm like on the office team obviously
he never said that i'm gonna stand up
for her boy yeah because that's a
[ __ ] lie reel the tapes
reel the tape up read it up and then she
sat back down and then he was hunter's
turn to pick he man stood up and said
guys i'm going to marry alexis sam guys
i want him he got so excited i want to
slap him back down i want to say if i
was nick lachey i'd have been like sit
the [ __ ] back down man shut up guys
beaming is it i want to marry alexis you
feel sorry for alexis that's why you
want to marry her yeah because you feel
sorry for her ah a little [ __ ] boy no
one wants your misses oh that's the
worst embarrassment that's the worst i
was thinking if there were x in this
show main ick is not getting picked by
anyone that's the worst feeling
how could no one want my missus
i couldn't
i genuinely couldn't imagine you're sat
there and no one wants your girl i'd
have to look myself in the mirror
because i know they're looking at me
do you know what i mean
raw
i couldn't be in there with you
watching your girl get pied and pied and
pied again i'll be looking at you like
bro
are you sure
i'd have to do a substitute we literally
can't pay for someone to be with your
wife that's embarrassing
i think it's worse from like the guy as
well if you're the guy i know yes
picking you
so embarrassing which brings me on to
nate
nate's a villain he's a villain of he
was the defending of the show i i wish
he stayed longer i wish he stayed longer
he was a villain
wow
he said if i'm going down
so is everyone yeah oh bro sorry i keep
itching my eye i got some [ __ ] hair
or something in my eyes killing me bro
nate
was
such a villain oh my goodness oh my
goodness
he spent the whole first week in his
head he was thinking i need to finesse
as many hoes as possible
i need to give them my all
he gave the ultimate a minute
he gave the ultimatum to his girl lauren
lauren because she doesn't want kids
kids and he needs kids
he needs that all he was talking about
throughout the whole team
first i want to be a dad he was talking
about i want to be a dad i want to be a
dad he thought he had shanique and april
wrapped up
he thought he had shanique and april
wrapped
what's wrong with me i said what the
[ __ ] is going on and then he's and then
he immediately turned to april and was
like i don't know what anyone else
thinks but me and abraham were like this
we had a connection we had a connection
we both want kids
abel stood up and said everything he
said is correct
what hunter did for men yeah yeah you
can't do this listens to man
hunter listens to man and that's what i
need i need a listener nate's not
listening it's a chat chat chatter
hunter listens and when i was having a
breakdown he was there he's the only one
there for me yeah literally he was on
one so i picked hunter nate said
no no no twice in one city in one
sitting
twice he got powered twice and then
hunter stood up and married alexis and
then hunter stood up and married alexis
and then nate's thinking i've got no one
left and he whispered to medley
has already been picked
madeleine's already been picked myself
i'm gonna choose him
i'm kind of cheesy
she's like what she's like what
who even are you i we've not we've moved
past monday i'm gonna choose you you
already know i'm with randall i chose
random and randall chose me what are you
honestly we're locked up
what are you actually on about you're
desperate he's clutching at straws
that it was [ __ ] um what's his name
colby's time to speak oh kobe laid it on
fish showered lauren
showered lauren
she was ready to leave her man oh honda
she was in a lift she was ready to leave
her
when alexis tried to say something about
kobe lauren jumped and defended him
facts
defended him
because i already saw it lauren and
colby seemed like they would bang
bro they would bang bro
lauren's a painting she's a baddie can't
stand her voice but she's a she's a
penguin daddy
the tats as well oh god sexy yeah hella
sexy so yeah lauren lauren was down down
down down down for colby
colby said everything before literally
before lauren was about to stand up to
pick whoever she was gonna appear she
was about to say copy let's go colby
let's [ __ ] go
nate stood up like a [ __ ]
after the fact that hunter already
proposed
he stood up
i don't want to take anyone's spotlight
but i need to do this i need to do this
i need there is no family without lauren
you're a waste man you're a liar you're
a lie you just did this because you've
got nothing like nothing left you're in
alexis shoes it's just you and alexis in
the corner
and you said you can't be stuck with her
yeah yeah yeah so yeah literally your
your only option was to to give up on
having kids or spend three weeks three
years with a lexus and you couldn't you
couldn't you could have fathomed
you couldn't fathom that
you thought [ __ ] it i'm going on one
knee i'd rather never have a kid
it's the only thing i want from my life
but i'd rather give up my only dream
than spend three weeks with this hope
then it's been three weeks so lauren
marry me please marry me please get me
off the show
my rating for lauren went from a hundred
and ten down to zero zero so she said
[ __ ] yes i couldn't believe she said
yes
bro when he got up and proposed or was
proposing
fam i was winston i wanted her to smack
i could have breathed i was like this
can't be possible literally one and she
can't ev she can't say yes surely she
can't say yes she must respect herself
enough to say no so this is going to be
embarrassing for everyone that brings me
on to kobe he's a cheat
a liar and a chi a liar and a [ __ ]
chief manipulative liar
he tried to get he tried to throw zay's
name under the bus our boys a
on guys night
i couldn't believe it man said
he was whispering to some yeah and out
of nowhere they tried to kiss me
they said no no no we're not playing
this little game you're a cheat so tell
everyone you're a chief and tell the
truth tell us what happened you lip said
don't say she tried to kiss you you
would throw me under the butt you were
lips in her
this that that's that's the episode that
got juicy
so just for context right for about what
what's happening to cover yeah yeah
so
so obviously colby's the one that gave
the ultimatum because he wanted to marry
his mrs madeleine
he's now
wanted to choose another chick i.e
lauren who then got proposed to and she
said yes so now he's stuck he ended up
choosing april which we'll come to yeah
and they've been coupling up for three
weeks now
so colby's now gone out with the mandem
and lipst another thing not even april
nothing to do with nothing to do with
the show
he's going to lips the random or offset
and then come back to tell the boys as
if to say zay was the one that tried to
persuade him to do it
brings me on to [ __ ] april
oh my god april is april she said she
was crazy yeah she's legitimately crazy
how can she say
her man is laying on the sofa oh so this
is fast forward april and jake original
couple
this is their back together now for
three weeks so this is after the fact
that jake was with ray who they picked
each other for the first few weeks so
april's back
she went through his apple watch was it
no she went iphone
because he came home drunk his phone was
unlocked went through it and we saw this
we saw the night vision in it she swiped
the phone oh 100 percent swiped the
phone swipe through it she saw rey's
arse twerking on the phone dropped the
videos to herself she was like i'm crazy
so i airdropped it to myself for proof
i couldn't believe that
i mean don't get me wrong i i get it
don't get me wrong of course i get it
everyone gets it i don't go through my
phone yeah don't go through my phone
violently yeah don't go through my phone
bro
she openly said it like i'm crazy so i
went for your phone and then i
airdropped everything to myself
because i know you're going to delete
them anyway
bye i airdropped them to myself
yo
knuck human [ __ ] this while i'm asleep
in the other room you're doing all of
this that's cute no she wasn't in he was
in bed she was at the foot of the bed
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah true the
night vision showed it all yeah i forgot
about it she didn't even leave the room
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] this show i'm gone
i'm gone bro 100 percent two and a half
years down the drain i'm gone yeah
i'm gone 100 you can't that's my one
cardinal rule you can never go through
my phone 100 you're crazy so that then
brings me on to jake and ray
yes
jake and ray so for context jake arrived
of april she gave him the ultimatum
um ray arrived with zay who will get
onto she gave him the ultimate and never
would have guessed it never would have
guessed it she gave him the ultimatum so
jake and ray are basically soul mates
they are they're basically someone's
from the second they started talking
they were clicking and clicking and
clicking anyway fast forward they picked
each other they moved in together and
they were lipped in in minutes
they were the first couple to lips they
were the first couple of lips she
lipsticked straight off the back and he
kept trying to back up a little bit and
she
gave me those lips
she was down yeah she was down she loved
jake
and this is the thing as well
these men are trying to tell us that
they didn't [ __ ] that whole three weeks
that's a lie some of them [ __ ] they
had a well i'm saying specifically jake
and ray okay because we know zayn
because of that box the sex box they had
a sex box
they had a sex box and these men are
trying to tell me they didn't fart
they're just tickling their feet and
[ __ ] with feathers blindfolds and
everybody to me
whose sex box was it
jake and rey's
because they found it when he came home
no no whose original sex box was it oh i
think it was jake's fa jake and april i
don't know no i think he bought it just
for him and ray no
yeah
i think he bought that box just for them
too mud yeah mad i'm i'm surprised zade
didn't punch someone oh
same
he went through it the whole time he had
a roller coaster of events oh he did
bless him he did bless him he did he did
he did he felt like he felt like the kid
of the show oh hundred percent but a lot
of times he acted like it towards the
end was the end he did like two-thirds
in he was acting like an idiot he was
frustrated
james you pushed they pushed him
they pushed my boys back you just push
and push and push eventually you're
gonna see the lion and that's what they
saw man went out and clapped someone's
cheeks 8 a.m you clap someone's cheeks
he went out on a night out frustrated
and [ __ ] someone 100 percent so
context um zay was with zay and ray were
the original couple yep zay went with um
shanique those are the two that they
picked each other so they were with each
other for three weeks then when they
came back with rey they spent three
weeks together during the first week
they were bickering and arguing and
jose was pouring his heart the thing
with rey rey isn't expressive ray's the
female by the way is the male just for
clarification so rey isn't expressive
about her emotions and her feelings
towards a even but she's more physical
she said i can show you she's always
like i can show you i can show you
family they [ __ ] every day their lips
all the time that stuff has frustrated
me that's the connection she has with
him whereas zay wants more than that he
wants
he wants to know tell me literally tell
me with words tell me how you feel about
me literally that's all he wants you
want to marry me yes or no why one if
you don't tell me why if you do tell me
why that's what he was asking throughout
the whole six weeks that's all he was
asking
so he asked her again he was saying to
her i'm ready to get engaged to you i'm
ready to do even though she gave him she
gave him the ultimatum and said i'm
ready to do everything with you blah
blah blah
she said she said
i can't speak about this right now i've
got a headache i need to shower i need
to go to bed she said my nose is running
my nose is money i need medicine i need
shower i need to go to bed mine said
please just tell me how you feel to me
i'm your man
two and a half years
bro
no wonder he went out to 8am [ __ ] you
and your texts oh 100 this is the thing
as well i was actually on zay's side
to a point
where like when he rolled out for that
after that
like appalling display yeah of me saying
to you look you bought me on this show
because you want to marry me yeah i've
spent three weeks without you i'm now
back and i'm telling you i'm ready to
get married let's basically lock the
show yeah the the point of the show has
been accomplished yeah thanks i'm ready
to get married let's go let's do it
thanks tell me how you feel how do you
feel she won't say nothing tell me how
you feel i'm trying to get married what
are you saying she said i just my nose
is running i want to go to bed
i said i bet say less say less so i'm on
his side
[ __ ] you in terms of oh you're not
allowed no matter what happened all
these all the girls all this stuff no
matter what happens you can't just roll
in at 8 a.m i'll do what i want thank
you very much because you're basically
telling me you don't want to be with me
without saying it facts i'm pouring my
heart to you and you won't even answer
me i'll come in in three days time if i
want to thank you very much
because i'm you're basically telling me
i'm single now yeah so i'll act single
fact if you're going to treat me like
[ __ ] i'll treat you like [ __ ] and i'll
rock up well i'll be home when i'm home
whenever i want to be home
they made him to be the villain in that
whole thing they did they didn't give a
[ __ ] about what drove him there
just about what he did
and then
in the uh thingy ray had that chest to
shout out at him
had that chester start shouting at him
and he was saying look i take full
accountability oh this is because him
and cheney banged
him and she looked banked
and he didn't tell her shanique told
randall but he didn't tell her so she
started going mad and he's trying to
tell her i take full accountability
she's not [ __ ] shouting at me so i'm
[ __ ] shouting him you're all shouting
at me
bro don't speak over me man's like
am i i'm just i'm in a different
dimension yeah i'm just talking
something he said someone help me he
literally turned to someone to help me
she's not listening man walked off oh he
walked off and said say less i'm done
with this yeah this is silly i'm done
with you and i'm done with this
run me my check and let me get out of
this silly little studio man cause
vanessa lachey is a manipulator herself
she cries when she wants to cry she
shouts when she wants to shout this is
the vanessa lashay show and i don't want
to be a part of it for another [ __ ]
second
that then brings me on to um randall and
uh madeline madeline oh
wanted to slob his knob marlin's a [ __ ]
from day one
she
who had
she went ten seconds into this show she
said him
before she even knew what she was there
for she said him i want him oh she is a
[ __ ] the sexual chemistry slash tension
they had
juicy oh juicy oh oh she wants the lips
from the jump a hundred percent [ __ ]
from the she was barling that they
didn't bang she was crying her eyes out
all the time and then
when she got twist up she's like why is
it when the cameras are off yo this and
that you're lifting me up every time the
camera's on bro i'm trying to [ __ ] you
don't want to do nothing you don't want
to do nothing
randall's
randall's an actor
he's an actor and i don't trust him for
that i don't trust him
i don't trust that boy as far as i can
throw him because he was manipulating
situations
he was listening her up off camera oh
lips in her up and she's in tears and
man's just like shh
stop stop stop stop
same thing with shane yep when they have
their little link up
i said i'm just doing the show i'm
trying to give the full experience you
invited me on the show yeah yeah yeah
yeah you gave me the ultimate that was
his fallback all the time you gave me
the ultimate me the ultimate
unfortunately if i would have been like
big man if you say automate it one more
[ __ ] time see what did you
bro
randall's a manipulator bro he's a
manipulator but you know i think randall
i think the only reason actually this is
mad
i actually don't think randall was
attracted to madeleine in the slightest
you think
i think
if you look at shanique and her
personality
i think randall just wanted a woman that
worships him
that's what i think he's looking for it
could have been madden it could have
been anyone else okay i think he just
got off on the fact of how badly she
wanted him because she told him from the
jump
and obviously she's not hideous
but i think the way randall saw
madeleine was just this is a yacht that
wants me to bend over backwards would
literally bend over bankwood's frontward
sideways wherever i want it because he
they asked about sex is there anything
off-limits she said nah i'll please my
man in all sorts oh she said i'll do
anything anything there's nothing off
limits he said anything she said
anything he got a solid boner
he got a solid she said that i don't
doubt that fam i would have been looking
at the sunset like let's go let's go
i would have covered my mic i'm like
let's go let's go yeah come on come on
yeah yeah yeah
he's just a bad muffin muffles yeah yeah
let's go come come try that come talk
i would have written it down
toilet i would have dipped my finger in
the pool and just run it on the concrete
let's swatch it off
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh she wanted to bang him all she wanted
to do she she wanted to do it so bad she
was crying her eyes
out like randall why why at the girls
girls drinks
went to shanique
randalls and maidens randall's this
randall's that she wanted to fight
she was ready to not gonna go back
upstairs and lips randall in front of
shanique
yo she didn't give a [ __ ] that's
disrespectful with her drunk eyes she
hasn't she was drunk throughout the
whole show
she was drunk throughout the whole show
it didn't make sense
madeline stayed drunk for the whole
ultimatum she stayed drunk from the
moment she arrived to the moment she lit
she was drunk too drunk throughout the
whole show bro okay cool so that brings
me on to shanique
shanique
in my opinion was the buffett on that
show
sam buffy is out on that show fam her in
the [ __ ] reunion
oh
shanique was beautiful in that whole
show buff is out in the show i was like
gang she's banging banging just even at
like parents yard and everything i was
just like bang she's got the best
genetics her dad looks my age
i couldn't believe that was her
father shanique and zay have sexual
tension they about three or four times
their [ __ ] sexual tension
i'm surprised they didn't just go at it
from the jump i'm surprised but every
time they got close they would ruin it
because
not
available
um that was it where she was put in the
face expressions ah okay so she would
say her part and then when he says his
part
she'll be like oh and he's like what's
with the if you want to say something
just say it and she's like ra like if
you can't even handle facial expressions
we can't do this we can't do this kind
of thing and he's like big man it's not
about that it's like he's even said like
it's not about the facial expressions
it's the fact that like you can say
something without talking you're clearly
saying something but you refuse to
verbalize it i'm just telling you to
verbalize it and she just walked off so
shanique and zay they had sexual tension
and then they actually [ __ ] that one
night didn't they
um
well it doesn't it doesn't say they
[ __ ] did they what did they say in the
reunion they just said fam
in the room
they didn't say they didn't say they're
[ __ ] but he said what's one thing you
learned from your partner and then
shanique said olive oil you can use as
lube
they [ __ ]
they [ __ ]
i can't believe she said that
because bro
i'm punching her in a temple are you
taking the piss out of me on live tv on
live television you're telling me you're
basically telling the world that homeboy
couldn't fit his fat dick in you so i
had to run around the kitchen looking
for lube naked naked
and lathered up some olive oil on there
and slid it in you
that's what you're telling the world
after i proposed and we're broken up now
yeah
no
man's prop man thought [ __ ] i wish i
[ __ ] with madeleine oh honey now she's
pregnant exactly when that's come round
he's thinking [ __ ] i wish i've banged
madeline because you were out here
getting clotted
by zay's fat dick you were getting
collided by six foot five zay
this sex would have popped i already
know the sex one oh well after they
rolled over panting in it oh yeah
her head scarf was a jar
hey
[Laughter]
they rolled over panting after they
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh
and they they were both frustrated with
what was going on yeah from all parties
yeah they needed to release
i don't know how do you i honestly don't
know how these men didn't bang every
night
i actually don't know how they didn't
bang every night saying after we [ __ ]
the first time we're banging
every single day in the morning
left i need to get foreign in i need to
get in i will deal with the
repercussions at the reunion because
doing it once or doing it 10 times is
the same [ __ ] i'm banged i've cheated so
we might as well go it's the ultimatum i
need to find out what i want to do do
you know what i mean and i'm still on
the fence so run me that tom again and
again again until i know that i'm sure
running those cheeks run me those
[ __ ] cheeks until i'm certain
please
[Music]